that afternoon is not going to be like
it is this morning and overnight we saw
this the absolutely spectacular blood
moon lunar eclipse the full moon for
November is known as the beaver Moon and
it turned red as the Earth's Shadow
passed over the moon man it was just
beautiful we were lucky enough that we
had some clearing in the clouds to be
able to see it won't get another total
lunar eclipse until March of 2025. so
hopefully you had a chance to see it of
course we'll have some pictures on our
website 8newsnow.com beautiful Skies we
look out from the city across the
mountains Shadows are dark over the
mountains this morning and we are
looking for widespread Gusty winds rain
increasing across the valley and snow
falling in our mountains as the day goes
on 50's across the valley this morning
it's cool not as cold as it's going to
be after this winter storm passes
through increasing winds and rain likely
this afternoon into tonight morning lows
for the end of the weekend the weekend
are going to drop into the low 40s and
chilly 30s and then we'll be staying
cool with highs below normal and clouds
at times all the way through the weekend
it's all because of this this really
chilly winter-like storm that will be
passing into California now and on its
way to Las Vegas Heavy Rain from San
Francisco down to the central coast and
Los Angeles has had a wet commute that
rain is spreading up through the desert
as we speak wind advisories go into
effect at noon those will last until 4
a.m tomorrow gusts to 50 miles an hour
expected again it is going to be quite
windy out on the roads and the snow well
winter storm warnings those are actually
elevated from winter storm advisories so
maybe two feet of snow above 7000 feet
68 degrees for the high today that's it
increasing chances for rain and those
strong Gusty winds so if you are going
to head to the polls I'd say go early
because this afternoon is not going to
be nearly as fun or easy to get out
around after tonight we'll see slight
chances for showers in the morning then
some sunshine tomorrow afternoon and
look at those temperatures staying just
under 60 degrees at times through
Veterans Day those mornings in the 30s
and low 60s for the weekend